Rabia for example I think this is very
well expressed in one of the most famous
quotes by Rabia which is where she says
basically that
talking to God she says if I worship you
out of desire for Paradise then lock the
gates To Paradise if I worship you for
fear of hell then you know throw me in
hell but if I worship you out of pure
love for you alone then do not deny me
your Everlasting Beauty it's a really
wonderful quote and it really
encapsulates that idea that that love of
God should be at the center of worship
not fear of Hell or wanting to go to
paradise because ultimately those are
egotistical selfish desires right